mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonjour en trois jours de conversation
le président georges pompidou et le
président richard nixon ont mis fin à
une décennie d'incompréhension et de
rapports tendus voilà l'impression qui
domine au lendemain de la visite
officielle du chef de l'état français
aux etats unis les deux hommes se sont
montrés très heureux d'avoir pu
converser directement
ils ont pu mieux se connaître et par
conséquent mieux se comprendre
bien sûr des désaccords subsistent un
certain nombre sur un certain nombre de
points le moyen-orient surtout et l'otan
notamment
mais le résultat est là et le résultat
est que les points d'entente sont
beaucoup plus nombreux qu'auparavant
la visite de monsieur pompidou vous le
savez ne s'arrête pas là elle ne
s'achève pas pour autant à washington
puisque le chef de l'état a visité hier
les installations de la nasa au cap
kennedy
il a emprunté le fameux ascenseur des
cosmonautes que l'on appelle depuis
d'ailleurs l'ascenseur du président il a
pu approcher au sommet de la fusée
saturn 5
la cabine apollo xiii qui le 11 avril
décollera pour la lune à 6 heures ce
matin heure de paris le président
pompidou et son épouse sont arrivés à
san francisco ils ont aussitôt gagné
l'hôtel st francis leur résidence mais
quelques heures avant leur arrivée on a
pu constater quelques manifestations à
l'aéroport il y avait plusieurs
centaines de personnes d'origines
israélite qui entendaient manifester
donc leur mécontentement à l'égard de la
politique française au moyen-orient
monsieur pompidou leur fera face
puisqu'il a décidé d' explique
d'expliciter la politique française au
moyen-orient à deux reprises une
première fois à san francisco et ensuite
à new york
hier à la maison blanche deuxième et
dernier entretien politique entre les
deux chefs d'état la rencontre plus long
que prévu a duré deux heures monsieur
nixon et monsieur pompidou ont ensuite
fait une brève déclaration à la presse
pour tirer les conclusions de cette
rencontre au sommet franco américaine
aïcha oui mais je peux dire que par
rapport à l'année dernière il y a un
grand progrès dans nos relations nous
avons établi nos relations des relations
telles qu'elles doivent être entre deux
pays qui ont été alliés pendant cent
quatre-vingt dix ans et ce pour la chose
de la cei de la liberté we are golden
abyss et nous ne sommes pas tombés
d'accord sur tous les sujets mais les
points sur lesquels nous nous entendons
sont beaucoup plus nombreux qu'il ya
quelques jours en outre nous sommes
convenus d'avoir des conversations
régulières constructive positive
non seulement ce qui concerne les
relations bilatérales mais aussi en ce
qui concerne l'attitude de nos deux pays
à renforcer la paix et la liberté dans
le monde du cadre j'ai le président vous
partez maintenant pour la floride la
californie enfin de chicago et new york
je vous assure que la grande majorité de
mes concitoyens vous réserve un accueil
chaleureux
l'accueil que mérite le président d'une
nation qui a été le plus vieil ami le
plus ancien allié des états unis lors de
votre retour en france je vous prie de
bien vouloir transmettre les amitiés du
peuple américain au peuple de france
hewson
ce que je voudrais dire surtout c'est
que j'ai été extrêmement sensible et
tous ceux qui m'ont accompagné en
particules émises d'affaires étrangères
ont été très sensibles à l'accueil
cordial direct spontané que vous nous
avez fait ici est que tout le monde nous
a faits et en particulier que je dois
dire combien j'étais sensible à
l'honneur de parler au congrès à
l'accueil que m'a fait le congrès
américain nous avons été très sensibles
à votre accueil à celui de madame nixon
à celui de tous les membres du
gouvernement américain toutes les
conversations que j'ai eues avec chacun
d'entre eux ont été directe franche
cordiale quand un président la
république française vient à washington
ça ne peut être qu'un ami des états unis
qui arrivent à washington jose pouvoir
dire qu'en quittant washington pour
continuer votre mon voyage dans votre
grand pays
c'est aussi un ami du président nixon
qui s'en va monsieur pompidou va
maintenant prendre congé du président
des états unis de la dernière poignée de
main et dans quelques instants
monsieur pompidou s'envolera pour cap
kennedy en floride dont nous allons
visiter
maintenant les installations spatiales
en compagnie de françois de closets
pour les visiteurs cap kennedy c'est
d'abord un immense bâtiment dominant le
plat paysage de floride le v abe le hall
où sont assemblés les fusée lunaire 160
mètres de haut le plus grand bâtiment du
monde qui dissimule son gigantisme dans
sa simplicité géométriques à côté du
verbe et la salle de contrôle où 450
console convié riches d'ici le lancement
mais dès que la fusée a décollé c'est
houston qui prend le relais chaque
pupitre ausculte à distance un des
organes de la fusée
puis le visiteur pénètre à l'intérieur
de la cathédrale de l'espace du pap les
fusées des prochains vols arrivant en
tronçons et sont préparés dans les nefs
latérales
les vaisseaux des missions à venir sont
déjà là
cette gigantesque installation
permettrait de tirer au moins 4 fusée
saturn 5 par an mais le rythme des
lancements n'est plus que d'un tous les
six mois
un transporteur un crawler attend
toujours aux côtés du verbe et le plus
gros véhicules du monde
ils portent 5000 tonnes chaque semelle
de la chenille en ps2 c'est ce véhicule
qui transporte la fusée du v abe jusqu'à
l'ère de lancement il transporte aussi
la tour mobile que voici
énorme échafaudage tubulaire permettant
d'accéder à la fusée quand elle se
trouve sur l'air de lancement enfin
l'orgueil de l'astronautique américaine
la saturn sainte l'outil de la victoire
apono la fusée attendait le président de
la république française sur son aire de
lancement
c'est elle qui dans un mois et demi
après avoir été dégagée de ces tours
emportera faire la lune les astronautes
d'apollo 13
dans la matinée le président de la
république sera reçu à la célèbre
université de stanford en californie où
il visitera le plus grand accélérateur
linéaire des états unis il déjeunera
ensuite en compagnie du gouverneur de la
californie monsieur reagan plus connus
du public américain pour ses talents
d'acteur de cinéma ce soir après une
réception parler de la légion d'honneur
monsieur pompidou aura tout simplement
quartier libre et pourra visiter la
ville sans doute la plus insolite des
états unis nommé ambassadeur des états
unis à paris depuis le 22 mars 1968
monsieur sargent shriver vient de
remettre sa démission au président nixon
il est vraisemblable que le président
attendra la fin de la visite de monsieur
pompidou pour faire connaître sa
décision à ce sujet monsieur schreiber
abandonnera la carrière diplomatique
pour se consacrer à la politique suite
de l'attentât dont a été victime la
caravelle autrichienne deux arabes
suspecté de complicité ont été arrêtés
hier soir à francfort il ils ont été vu
en compagnie de moussa ya verts qui est
actuellement au caire est de ras dika
doumic voici qui doit toujours se
trouver en allemagne fédérale ces deux
derniers sont les auteurs présumés de
l'attentât contre la caravelle
autrichienne nouvelles de france au
terme d'une journée relativement
mouvementée 676 jeunes gens ont été
interpellés
hier au quartier latin tandis que toute
manifestation vous en souvenez était
interdite
le doyen ricoeur doyen de la faculté de
lettres de nanterre a annoncé
officiellement qu'il n'était pas en
mesure d'assurer la sécurité des
enseignants des étudiants et des
personnels face aux violences commises à
nanterre par des éléments extrémistes
étrangers à la faculté a précisé le
doyen dans une déclaration il a révélé
que ces violences atteignait un
paroxysme telle qu'on pouvait craindre
que des meurtres ne soit commis il ya
quinze jours a révélé le doyen un jeune
homme non casqué a été frappé à la tête
à coups de barres de fer et il a été
laissé pour mort et l'on se demande si
l'intention des agresseurs n'étaient pas
justement de donner la main voilà quel
est le cri d'alarmé que vient de lancer
le doyen rigueur à ce cri le ministre de
l'éducation nationale a répondu
conjointement avec le ministre de
l'intérieur la surveillance et la
circulation sur les voies du domaine
universitaire seront considérés comme
ouvert au public
cette surveillance sera donc assurée par
la police et la présence des forces de
l'ordre à l'extérieur des bâtiments
universitaires aura pour but de faire
disparaître du campus les ventes les
bandes 2 armés qui y sévissent pour
l'instant précise-t-on au ministère mais
dominique leriche vous étiez ce matin à
nanterre pouvez vous nous faire le point
de la situation
écoutez moi je reviens à l'instant de la
faculté de nanterre est ce que je peux
vous dire ce qu'il y règne le plus grand
calme
apparemment les décisions qui ont été
prises hier par le ministre l'intérieur
émises litres de l'éducation nationale
ne sont pas impliqués en effet après la
déclaration du doigt hyaric heures et la
décision du ministre de faire pénétrer
directement la police sur les allées du
campus sans attendre la réquisition du
doyen on pouvait penser que les forces
de l'ordre allaient prendre position dès
ce matin à l'antenne elles ont pris
position mais à l'extérieur du campus
comme vous pouvez le constater aucun
uniforme sur les années les étudiants
suivent les cours
c'est le calme le plus complet vous le
voyez alors que s'est il passé
et on peut se poser une question on peut
se demander si le doyen et le ministre
ont fait marche arrière
c'est la question que j'ai posée à un
collaborateur du doyen il m'a répondu
par une boutade
les allées sont déclarés voix
public c'est à dire que la police peut y
faire des rondes à n'importe quelle
heure du jour et de la nuit
comme dans toutes les rues de paris
d'ailleurs mais at il ajouté les rondes
cela ne se fait pas tout le temps voilà
quelle est la situation mais elle peut
évoluer d'un moment à l'eau bon en tout
cas cette situation vous la surveiller
bien sûr bien entendu je serai cet après
midi à la faculté de nantes
merci dominique laurie le coût de la vie
s'est élevé en 1970 en janvier c'est ce
qu'annonce officiellement le ministère
des finances
l' indice des prix s'établit à 134,1
pour janvier 70 contre 133 pour décembre
69 à la suite de l'accord passé entre la
direction de la sncf et les syndicats à
l'exception de cgt les salaires des
cheminots ils sont 300 7000 sont
augmenté de 3,4 pour cent le 1er avril
prochain et de 2,6 le 1er octobre au
plus tard
et vous vous souvenez qu'il y avait eu
une augmentation le 1er janvier dernier
reçus par les producteurs de lait
monsieur jacques duhamel ministre de
l'agriculture a subi le feu roulant de
sévères questions posées par les
producteurs de lait très mécontents
premières mesures prises par le ministre
est annoncé dès hier une augmentation de
deux centimes par litre de lait cette
augmentation est consécutive à la
dévaluation conducteur attention la
commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale vient de mettre au point un
projet de loi instituant un taux légal
de l'alcoolémie
le taux de 0,8 a été retenue pour
caractériser la conduite sous l'empiré
de l'alcool
il y aura donc contraventions entre 0 g
8 et 1 g 8
au delà il y aura des lits mais ce texte
je vous le précise n'a pas pour but de
vous empêcher de boire il veut
simplement vous empêcher de conduire
après avoir bu informations générales
sur le front des inondations la
situation est toujours préoccupante
d'une manière générale les eaux
continuent de monter à paris la gare des
invalides pourrait peut-être être fermé
rapidement
certains ponts sont surveillés le pont
de l'alma précisément où la circulation
pourrait être
stoppez on circule toujours en barque à
villeneuve saint georges et à conflans
sainte honorine certaines zones
d'habitations ont été évacuées
la dernière grande crue de la saône
remonte à une quinzaine d'années on
avait noté si m à trévoux au même
endroit hier il y avait déjà près de 5
mètres et la crue continue on s'attend à
voir des bas quartiers de mâcon inondées
dans certains villages on commence non
seulement à s'inquiéter d'apprendre des
mesures pour déménager le mobilier du
rez de chaussée
en certains endroits les eaux s'étale
sur plusieurs kilomètres de largeur
tantôt rhône il est de nouveau stable
depuis hier après-midi dans la traversée
de lyon
les spécialistes en fin de compte sont
assez optimistes
il pense que la décrue de la saône
devrait s'amorcer dans quatre ou cinq
jours
et en allemagne c'est au minimum à une
quinzaine de morts que s'élève le bilan
des inondations qui sévissent depuis
quelques jours bien que le niveau de la
plupart des rivières et baissé mercredi
le rhin le maine et le danube ne cesse
de monter des milliers d'hectares de
terres sont recouverts par les eaux dans
la région de bonn et de cologne on
n'avait pas vu une telle catastrophe
depuis 70 ans
les dégâts se chiffrent par mise sur la
rive gauche du rhin la plupart des
routes sont coupées à partir de coblence
ce trafic ferroviaire est rassuré n'est
assurée que sur la rive droite la
bundeswehr et tous les services publics
viennent au secours des nombreux
sinistrés une décrue général est attendu
aujourd'hui
je crois que le temps s'est apparemment
améliorée dans certaines régions dans
l'est
il fait froid il neige encore quelque
peu dans le nord où il fait froid le
soleil brille depuis ce matin en
bretagne il fait très beau depuis
quelques heures
dans le sud-ouest la tempête souffle par
contre dans sur les pyrénées et en
altitude de nombreux cols sont fermés
dans le centre
il fait froid le temps est couvert il a
neigé cette nuit mais la circulation est
normale dans les halles qu'une bonne
nouvelle il fait très beau en savoie y
en haute savoie
pratiquement toutes les pistes sont
ouvertes à val d'isère et à tignes les
skieurs sont revenus et les pistes sont
à nouveau praticables à tignes la
situation sera sans doute normal dès
demain des équipes travaillent jour et
nuit à la remise en route des remontées
mécaniques et le beau temps devrait
faciliter le ravitaillement de bonneval
sur arc
bonneval sur arc la petite station
savoyarde est depuis quinze jours isolé
du reste du monde
elle est bloquée par la neige comme elle
l'est d'ailleurs chaque année à pareille
époque c'est par hélicoptère pour le
village et ravitaillé c'est surtout le
problème du pain qui est le plus crucial
aussi de nombreux boulangers des
villages des environs conjuguent leurs
efforts pour fournir pour plusieurs
jours le pas nécessaire aux habitants de
bonneval les hivernants souffre
nullement de cette situation il fait
beau le ravitaillement est assurée et
les chalets affiche pratiquement complet
c'est dire que les habitués de bonneval
jura passe un agréable séjour en dépit
des mauvaises conditions d'accès du
village le village sera sans doute
dégager dans quelques jours fusion s'est
produite l usine à gaz de chambéry ce
matin et le gaz de france demande aux
usagers de chambéry d'aix-les-bains et
d'annecy de ne se servir en aucun cas de
leur appareil d'utilisation et à lille
un incendie dramatique
l'incendié qui s'est déclaré hier
après-midi à loos près de lille n'aurait
pu être qu'un banal sinistre de mansarde
et pourtant il a fait trois morts et
quatre blessés
le feu a pris au second étage de
l'immeuble plusieurs personnes s'y
trouvaient une mère de famille pitt à
peine le temps de sauver l'un de ses
enfants en le précipitant par la fenêtre
l'enfant n'est que blessé une bouteille
de gaz butane chauffé à blanc explosait
brûlant grièvement deux sapeurs pompiers
un autre sapeur perdre l équilibre et
faisaient une chute de plus de 6 mètres
le feu redouble et à l'heure de violence
l'espoir de retrouver vivants les trois
personnes qui se trouvaient encore dans
la mansarde s'évanouissaient vers 16
heures
l'incendié était maîtrisé dans les
décombres on retrouvait alors les corps
carbonisés
les trois malheureuses victimes on
ignore pour l'instant les causes de la
santé nous parlons sport maintenant avec
patrick chapuis de ski tout d'abord il
ya ce kyste d'avant couvert la première
manche du slalom géant et c'est
l'autrichien walter brenner qui a gagné
il précède à la peines de 16 centièmes
et patrick russel de 98 centièmes karl
schranz qui était grippé et 9e à près de
deux secondes
la deuxième manche aura lieu aujourd'hui
et russell à l'attention de prendre tous
les risques car ils essayent de se
rapprocher de carl chances au classement
de la coupe du monde handball les
championnats du monde organisés par la
france ont commencé hier soir ils
dureront jusqu'au 8 mars
l'équipe de france a fait hier soir
d'excellents débuts face au favori
roumain il ne s'est incliné que par
trois buts d'écart
12 but à 9 ici le roux banica dit aux
six mètres mais il se fait prendre la
balle paris chat à droite vous
reconnaissez bernard sellenet le gardien
français
cyclisme le belge patrick cyr qu a
finalement remporté le tour de sardaigne
basket maintenant vous allez voir un
film qui nous vient de lyon vous
souvenez qu'en coupe d'europe des clubs
lors du match aller l'équipe de
villeurbanne avait été battu par l'armée
rouge de moscou écrasé même hier soir en
match retour
l'asvel a beaucoup mieux joué éliminer
tout de même de la coupe
asbel fait une sortie en beauté devant
son public c'est un reportage qui nous
vient de lyon
les basketteurs de villeurbanne à gauche
sur votre écran en short blanc ont
disputé hier soir au palais des sports
de gerland
leur dernier match de la poule quarts de
finale de la coupe d'europe là tu sur un
écart de 39 points au match aller qu'ils
n'avaient aucune chance de gagner mais
ils se sont inclinés avec les honneurs
devant le ts cas de moscou 99 à 90
pourtant en première mi temps les russes
plus athlétique avait fait la différence
ils menaient de 19 points à la pause
mais à la reprise les villeurbannais
gilles en tête se déchaînaient regarder
au ralenti le capitaine de l'asvel se
jouait de la défense moscovite et les
français revenaient bientôt à dix points
des russes dommage que le pivot
international alain durand n'ai pu jouer
en raison d'une blessure au genou car le
match aurait été sans doute plus serré
encore il fallait toute la taille et
2016 et le talent d'un bref pour éviter
au joueur russe une courte défaite
terminant 3e de la poule quarts de
finale derrière moscou et varèse et
devant belgrade
l'asvel est éliminé de la coupe d'europe
nous apprenons à l'instant la nouvelle
d'un grave accident qui se serait
produit à rennes
trente trois élèves du ce1 ce2 rennes
qui circulait en canoë sur le canal qui
traverse la ville ont chaviré
on aurait récupéré pour l'instant 27
élèves du ce1 s4 serait en salle de
réanimation mais on est sans nouvelles
de six jeunes gens et jeunes filles de
14 à 15 ans il est possible toutefois
qu'il se soit rendu directement dans
leur famille pourriez vous montrer une
photo jacqueline alexandre maintenant
c'est une photo de madame pompidou qui
hier quitté encore payer son époux le
président des états unis elle portait un
manteau de renard roux mais auparavant
bodin pompidou avait visité la national
gallery à new york
je pense que nous allons voir des images
oui je pense d'ailleurs que ce n'était
pas de new york
monsieur et madame pompidou aime la
peinture
ce n'est plus un secret les trois
journées que le président français a
passé à washington
en effet véritable course contre la
montre ne lui ont pas laissé le temps de
visiter les musées
en revanche le programme madame pompidou
prévoyait une halte à la national
gallery halte prise surtout devant des
toiles française ici renoir
et quelques jeunes quelques-unes des
oeuvres maîtresses de la période bleue
de picasso
deux fois par an la haute couture
présente ses créations
c'est aujourd'hui le grand jour le jour
de sortie des collections printemps été
vous allez voir un reportage dé islami
réalisé par bernard de flandre dans les
studios de jean bart est à paris ce
matin sortie de la mode printemps-été
une nouvelle femme est née moins
sportive plus élancée silhouette longue
taille à sa place
j'y vais doucement et basé longueur
variable dont voici le nouveau
dictionnaire maxi à la cheville midi au
mollet courroux genou et mini le plus
haut possible nette préférence cependant
des couturiers pour la longueur midi le
pantalon lui est large très large
youtube
selon le modéliste
et
plus
oui
bon
et
nous
tous
e
et
les images de ce reportage était d'alain
petiet nous avons pris un tout petit peu
de retard c'est pourquoi ils ont tout de
suite passé la parole à gérard vidal
hanche à la bourse de paris